umberto eco herzlich willkommen in der
sternstunde philosophie
die philosophie ist auf der suche nach
dem wahren guten und schönen ist denn
die vernunft ein guter begleiter auf dem
weg zu einem guten leben
das ist eine frage zur geschichte der
philosophie im namen der vernunft wurden
auch verbrechen begangen
für mich gibt es etwas wichtigeres als
die verkaufen wie etwas sehr abstraktes
ist es ist das vernünftig sein
die fähigkeit sich zu verständigen und
die rahmenbedingungen des gesprächs zu
bestimmen und zwar auf vernünftige weise
es ist nicht die vernunft von hegel
sondern die vernunft der verhandlungen
durch das ist fundamental für das leben
der menschen für ein friedvolles leben
es kommt immer darauf an wie man die
vernunft definiert heißt das ist denn
diese vernunft die sie definieren
geeignet um die welt zu verstehen denn
man stellt regeln auf ohne darauf zu
pochen sie seien absolut trotzdem hält
man sich an diese regeln das kann auch
eine regel die etikette sein wie zum
beispiel dass man nicht mit den fingern
in der nase bohrt dass man beim essen
das messer mit der rechten hand führt
dass man den hut ab nimmt bevor man eine
kirche betrifft das sind sie sind nicht
absolut man könnte die kirche auch mit
aufgesetztem buch betreten gewisse
frauen tragen einen schleier die japaner
machen beim essen geräusche die bei uns
als ungezogen geld regeln sind also
nicht absolut
aber man kann regeln vereinbaren
und anstatt sich umzubringen auf der
grundlage dieser regeln miteinander
diskutieren
das ist übrigens auch die natur des
spiels vom schach bis zum programm
man kann so viele partien spielen lieber
an will aber es gibt regeln die
verhindern dass man betrügt oder die
pistole zieht und auf seine gegner
schießt das ist sehr wichtig die antwort
erstaunt mich weil ich habe immer
gedacht umberto eco versucht ein die
ganze welt einzuordnen zu verstehen aber
mit dem denken das ist der beruf des
philosophen aber ich möchte nicht alles
erklären
zudem ist die philosophie sie wissen die
disziplin die fragen stellt auf die es
keine antwort gibt es antworten wäre
seine wissenschaft wie die chemie oder
die für sie da wo es um fragen geht auf
die es keine antworten gibt zb was ist
vernunft da beginnt die philosophie und
wenn man aus der philosophie keine
religion machen wenn man also nicht sagt
ich weiß was vernunft bedeutet und
bringe dich um weil du das anders sie
ist hält man sich an die regel des
vernünftig sein
das ist eine wenig romantische
definition der philosophie aber ich
finde eine zutiefst menschliche wir sind
mittendrin
viele kennen sie als den schriftsteller
den autor von dem roman der name der
rose vom forschen pendelt wir möchten
sie heute auch etwas kennenlernen als
philosophen als semiotik dass sie auch
sind sie haben jahrelang in bologna
gelehrt sie sind heute noch an der
universität dort tätig wir möchten sie
als sprach philosophen kennenlernen
ihr neuestes werk heißt die unendliche
liste
sie beschäftigen sich damit mit
aufzählungen
mit liebsten mit katalogen in der
geschichte der literatur und der kunst
aber auch wieder ein versuch die welt
ordnend zu fassen ist dieser wunsch mit
der menschheit gegeben seit anfang an
ja aber die liste ist kein versuch die
welt zu ordnen sondern genau das
gegenteil sie haben einige meiner bücher
erwähnt wir haben über die philosophie
gesprochen
wenn wir jetzt über dieses buch reden
beginne ich mit homer in der ilias
beschreibt er an einem gewissen punkt
den schild der sache und zwar als
vollkommener runde scheibe vulkan hat
verschiedenes themen darauf dargestellt
die who mehr detailliert beschreibt lisa
schild bildet eine in sich geschlossene
welt außerhalb gibt es nicht alles was
man wissen muss beinhaltete schützt das
ist die vollkommene form und vielleicht
die welt wie sie die philosophen gerne
sehen dann soll mir sagen wie viele
griechen vor troja stehen aber er kann
es nicht
es sind zu viele sagt der moose hilf mir
das schaffe ich nicht und er beginnt
eine weste zu erstellen er zählt die
schiffe auf und die kapitäne und was
typisch ist für eine liste sie wird
nicht auf es gibt immer sein schreiben
dieses buches ist zudem aufgefallen dass
es in der geschichte des denkens einen
unaufhörlichen kampf gibt zwischen der
definition nach substanz unter
definition durch eigenschaften was ist
eine deflation zum start der mensch ist
ein vernunftbegabter des sterbliche stil
das pferd ist ein säugetier aus der rock
der unbaren dann gibt es die definition
nach eigenschaften wenn ein kind seine
mutter fragt was ist ein tiger antwortet
sie ein großes tier das aussieht wie
eine katze ein gelbes fell mit schwarzen
streifen hat und brüllt
die wenig entwickelten gesellschaften
die dinge noch nicht nach ihrer substanz
definieren konnten erstellten lange
listen von eigenschaften aber auch
hochentwickelte gesellschaften nach dem
17 jahrhundert taten das wenn sie
existierende definitionen nach substanz
verwarfen und neue listen erstellen
die liste ist also eine möglichkeit
unser wissen zu erweitern den
definitionen nach substanz nicht mehr
zufriedenstellend sind
da war schon wieder die verbindung mit
der philosophie drin
jetzt ist das projekte ausgegangen von
einer ausstellung im louvre
also es geht um bilder und texte in
diesem reich bebilderten band wo ist
denn die verbindung von ließen zwischen
bildern und texten
ich habe mein projekt begonnen ohne im
geringsten an die philosophische
erklärung zu denken die ich eben ergeben
habe mit anderen worten man muss den
eigenen wünschen und leidenschaften
nachgehen und die philosophische
erklärung kommt hinterher
der louvre lädt seit einigen jahren die
wahl im november eine persönlichkeit der
kultur als gastkurator ein gäste waren
zum beispiel die schriftstellerin toni
morrison der komponist pierre boulez ist
oder der künstler anselm kiefer als ich
eingeladen wurde kam er als thema die
liste intensiv denn sie beschäftigt mich
schon lange ließ man meine romane sind
sie voller ließ liebsten machen mir spaß
sie sind wie gesänge zu den diensten
ließen gehören digitalen der kirche sie
sind wie man mit ästhetik zu tun
bei der vorbereitung der verschiedenen
veranstaltungen die im november im nova
stattfinden werden es geht
warum dieses buch es wird konzerte geben
vorträge ausstellungen autorenlesungen
alle zum thema der liste bei den
vorbereitungen sind verschiedene fragen
ausgeräumt
es ist klar was eine literarische liste
ich habe um mehr es liest oder
kriegsschiff erwähnt man könnte das
zweitletzte kapitel von julius von james
joyce wählen indem er alle dinge
auflistet die sich in der
küchenschublade von leopold bloom
befinden
eine liste setzt immer ein um zu weiter
voraus sie hat kein ende gibt es listen
in der malerei der maler schließt eine
szene ja in sein bild ein
der betrachter wird nicht dazu
eingeladen zu sehen was nachher kommt
oder sich zum beispiel hinter der mona
lisa versteckt in der malerei gibt es
also keine listen als wäre doch
umständen haben wir zum beispiel die
bilder des berühmten italienischen
malers giovanni paolo panin aus dem
17ten jahrhundert gesehen
er malte museen mit jede menge
gemäldegalerien in denen an den wänden
bild neben bild neben bild wenn man also
ein bild von ihm betrachtet sieht nun
weitere bilder darauf und ahnt dass es
10.000 millionen sind die ja gar nicht
alle abbilden konnte dann haben wir
niederländische maler gesehen die
tausende von fischen oder feuchten
darstellten oder bilder mit dem titel in
10.000 märtyrer auf denen aber 950
abgebildet sind und man sich die anderen
vorstellen muss oder gewisse gemälde des
deutschen malers albrecht altdorfer auf
denen riesige kriegsjahre abgebildet
sind die sich in der ferne verlieren und
dir zu verstehen geben dass es tausende
krieger sehr mit der zeit haben wir alle
in diesem buch vereinten bildern
gefunden
ziemlich unerwartete bilder weil sie
etwas auf listen für die ausstellung im
louvre haben wir zudem auch musik ließ
er gefunden und so weiter
dass das wissen gesteigert werden soll
aber gibt es denn überhaupt noch etwas
das wir nicht wissen gibt es noch lücken
des wissens
ich denke schon
wir wissen nicht einmal ob es den
urknall gegeben hat oder nicht
eine eigner des wissens ist das ist
ständig lücken aufweist
ich gehe noch weiter und vage eine
stärke philosophische aussage auf die
jedoch mal die welt das wissen wird in
haft seien
denn dem wissen ist dass irgendwas
charles pierce fallis musste nämlich
dass man sich immer irren oder wie karl
popper sagte wenn man eine theorie
verkündet muss man auch all die beweise
nennen wie deren falschheit belegen wird
auch wenn man also glaubt den
definitiven beweis für eine theorie zu
haben hat man die pflicht weiterhin zu
bezweifeln was man zu wissen man muss
eine hypothese falsifizieren um
herauszufinden ob es nicht weitere dinge
gibt die wir noch nicht wissen auch wenn
sich das wissen immer wieder als system
präsentiert wird daraus im laufe der
geschichte eine unendliche liste von
lösungen sie gehen ja als sehr wacher
zeitgenosse wird die welt und allen
bereichen diese listen nahmen sie kommen
auch auf das world wide web auf unserer
internet und sagen es ist eigentlich so
was wie ein spinnennetz klingt nicht so
positiv vor allem muss man eine
unterscheidung machen die ich in meinem
buch gleich zu beginn an stellen und die
übrigens nicht von mir stammt die
unterscheidung zwischen praktischen und
poetischen ist auf einer praktischen
liste stehen dinge die existieren und
zwar in endlicher zahl zum beispiel die
liste der bücher meiner bibliothek
oder das telefonbuch darin stehen alle
besitzer eines telefonanschlusses in
zürich oder frankfurt
nicht mehr und nicht weniger das ist
eine endliche liste zudem dient sie dazu
existente personen zu finden
es ist also nicht ein buch das man liest
ausgenommen gewisse leute mehr als ein
telefonbuch literarische listen hingegen
können sich auch auf den beziehen die
nicht existieren
zum beispiel die liste der bücher die
labile in seinem roman die agentur anp
am tag ruhe macht es sind liest um das
bloße vorliebe für listen erstellt
wurden um der liste willen und diese
sind unendlich
was nun ist das internet man könnte
meinen seine praktische liste denn es
enthält alle webseiten zu einem gewissen
thema aber es ist auch potenziell
unendlich das heißt wenn jemand jede der
millionen seiten anklickte während die
ersten bereits wieder verschwunden und
durch andere ersetzt wenn er am ende
angelangt wäre theoretisch kann man also
bis in alle unendlichkeit im internet
surfen hinzu kommt dass es gar nicht
sicher ist ob die webseiten von wirklich
existenten dingen berichten
denn viele sind falsch enthalten
fantasien oder historische übertrieben
das internet ist ein ziemlich neues
phänomen in der geschichte der listen
denn es ist unendlich und somit
schwindelerregend sprachen heißt der
titel meines buches auch entsprechend
auf deutsch war es nicht
weil schwindel zwei verschiedene
bedeutungen hat deshalb heißt es die
unendliche liste aber listen sind oft
schwindelerregend als schaute man von
einem berg oder einem wolkenkratzer in
den abgrund hinunter auch das internet
ist schwindelerregend ohne jedoch die
poetische qualität der literarischen
listen aufzuweisen
aber sie hätten sich machen an diesem
schwindel aus nutzen sie das internet
natürlich so wie ich das auto benutzer
aber nicht überfahren werden möchte das
auto kann mich töten aber auch nützlich
sein
das internet ist wie das auto man solle
weil man es braucht
doch es gibt menschen die sich davon in
den abgrund ziehen lassen
sie surfen tag und nacht darin bom und
finger nicht mehr aus diesem strudel
diesem labyrinth heraus wissenschaftler
kann ich mich natürlich nicht von der
unendlichkeit des internets blenden
lassen sondern muss jede einzelne seite
prüfen und schauen ob sie die wahrheit
enthält oder nicht
aus der liste greife ich also einzelne
seiten heraus
aber wissen sie was wir die
schwindelerregende liste genannt haben
finden wir schon bei kann
er sprach über das gefühl des erhabenen
angesichts des sternen übersäten himmels
über sich was ist eine solche unmenge
von sternen dass mir die begrenztheit
meiner subjektivität bewusst wird
gegenüber dieser unendlichkeit die ich
nie erreichen kann
ich empfinde also nichts schönheit
sondern erhabenheit angesichts von
achill schild wird erkannt gesagt
verspürt man das gefühl die schönen aber
angesichts der liste der kriegsschiffe
das gefühl dass erhaben
auch im internet entdecken sie die
philosophie gehen wir noch zurück ins
1400 der name der rose und zwar
letztlich geht es ja in ihrem roman auch
um eine philosophische frage und zwar um
ein buch von aristoteles die beute über
das komische und darin geht es um das
lachen
also das ist eigentlich letztlich dieses
buch dessentwegen die ganzen morde
geschehen und eigentlich ist der blinde
seher der dieses buch vor den anderen
verstecken will keiner keine soll es
sehen und in dem buch stolz sehen in
diesem buch von aristoteles geht es um
folgendes ich zitiere aristoteles sieht
in der anlage und bereitschaft zum
lachen ein gutes bewirken die kraft die
auch erkenntniswert haben kann wenn die
komödie durch witzige oder geistreiche
rätsel und überraschende metaphern in
welchem die dinge anders dargestellt
werden als sie sind also gleichsam durch
lügen uns zwingt genauer hinzuschauen
ich bin jetzt ganz ehrlich als ich der
name der rose geschrieben habe dachte
ich in keiner weise an die
philosophischen probleme die hinterher
alle darin entdeckt haben
ich wollte eine geschichte erzählen die
mittelalter spielt um da ich mich in
büchern auskenne wurde seine geschichte
über bücher wäre ich pädophil hätte ich
über die pädophilie geschrieben aber ich
habe nun mal das mittelalter studieren
ohne zu wollen habe ich große
philosophische fragen aufgegriffen
diese wurden aber erst hinterher von
einem verschiedenen sektoren und
übersetzern entdeckt damit will ich
sagen dass mir das nicht bewusst war und
ohne es zu wollen habe ich durch die
figuren in meinem buch
so fischen fragen auf den grund gehen
viele meine ideen einfließen lassen und
die des lachens ist grundlegend jahre
lang trug ich mich mit dem gedanken ein
buch über die ästhetik des lachens zu
schreiben denn keiner der darüber
geschrieben hat erklärt das phänomen wie
dior louis bergson noch rollt noch
andere
doch das problem schien nie so komplex
dass ich es nie angepackt habe und ohne
es zu merken bin ich es in diesem roman
angekommen
ich hatte eine idee von lehrern kopf
nämlich das lachen metro fisch sei das
heißt wenn man lacht nimmt man die
wahrheit nicht ernst
wir sind im mittelalter als man die
menschen wegen der wahrheit auf dem
scheiterhaufen verbrannt
wenn man also die wahrheit nicht ernst
nahm war das ein akt der rebellion auch
beim schreiben dieses romans habe ich
noch etwas verstanden dass darin nicht
vorkommt warum ist der mensch das
einzige tier das lacht bei den anderen
tieren zb bei den affen im scheint es
vielleicht manchmal als ob sie lachen
würden aber sicher sind wir nicht
zudem umfasst das lachen nicht nur das
gelächter das ausdruck von freude oder
wut sein kann
es umfasst den humor die loni die satire
wie schon aristoteles gesagt und trouble
wiederholt tat scheint das lachen nur
dem menschen neigen zu sein
warum der mensch hat noch eine eintrag
besonderheit als einziges tier weise an
seiner sterblichkeit mein hund weiß es
nicht
er sieht andere sterben
und wird eines tages selber sterben aber
er versteht nicht dass alle hunde
sterblich sind
während wir menschen um unsere
sterblichkeit wissen dieses wissen
ärgert und sein werk machte uns ein
wenig unzufrieden
deshalb haben wir doktrinen über die
unsterblichkeit ausgearbeitet und viele
andere wichtige dinge aber die einzige
zutiefst menschliche reaktion auf das
wissen dass wir sterben müssen uns
darüber zu lachen und es mit humor zu
nehmen
ich denke der mensch ist zum lachen
gekommen weil er weiß dass er sterben
muss also legen wir das auch noch offen
sie haben ja eine doktorarbeit
geschrieben über thomas von aquin den
großen kirchenlehrer philosophen
theologen aus dem dreizehnten
jahrhundert also ich sehe in der
rezeption des thomas von aquin dass er
versucht den menschen gegenüber den
göttlichen wir sind ja mitten im
hochmittelalter wo der mensch nichts zu
melden hat nach augustinus ist der
mensch so klein und gott ist so groß
dass alles so zu sagen thomas von aquin
für den menschen ein steht thomas von
aquin ist eine seltsame persönlichkeit
und zwar weil ein gewisser hinsicht ein
christdemokrat zu sein scheint er
versuchte immer alle zu einigen
wenn sich auch mit dem papst zu
verstehen in anderer hinsicht war
hingegen revolutionieren einerseits
hatte einen wirklich revolutionären
versucht gewagt nämlich die lehre
aristoteles in die katholische theologie
einfließen zu lassen
andererseits versucht er aristoteles zu
christianisieren und ihn für alle
akzeptierbar zu machen
nun zur wahrhaft philosophischen lehre
die der heilige thomas uns hinterlassen
hat denn er hatte eine klare vorstellung
von vernunft diese ermöglichte ihm die
existenz gottes zu beweisen
womit kann nicht einverstanden gewesen
wäre aber damit irgendwann seine große
fähigkeit vernünftig zu sein und das ist
die lektion die ich von ihm gelernt habe
die questico die typische frage von
thomas von aquin die typische form jedes
philosophischen kapitäns verfolgen zum
argument iks findet man erst muss das
datum das aber andere sagen darüber auch
dass das und wieder andere sagen
dazu könnte man nun folgen die sachen b
aber dagegen spricht aussage darauf
sagte ein schlichtes im latein jetzt
antworte ich und versucht alle visionen
zu ordnen während thomas von aquin teil
seiner antworten eine große ordnung an
den tag legte hatte er den mut sich im
voraus allen anderen ideen zu stellen
und auch jene zu erwähnen die ihm
schaden konnten und er deshalb auch
hinter verschweigen können
das sind mut beweisen sie aber nicht auf
den ersten blick entdeckt denn sein wert
ist so immens dass viele dinge
untergehen wie sie wissen war eine der
großen häsin die ewigkeit der welt wenn
die welt seit jeher existiert und ewig
braucht es gott nicht
wer also von der ewigkeit der welt
überzeugt war galt als atheistische
tipps wie der philosoph sieger von
brabant und viel an wenn man liest was
thomas von aquin in seinen
untersuchungen über die wahrheit über
die ewigkeit der welt geschrieben hat
findet man erstaunliches er prüft alle
argumente und sagt dem licht der
vernunft kann ich nichts sagen ob die
welt.de dich ist oder nicht aus
glaubensgründen nehme ich an dass sie
nicht ewig ist aber philosophisch kann
ich es nicht beweisen
das ist sehr mutig
am schluss seines lebens sagt thomas von
aquin in einer eingebung ich weiß es
nicht alles was ich gedacht habe ist
stroh das was ihnen eine regierung
gesehen habe das zelt hatten sie auch
mal so ein erlebnis
zuerst einmal war ein heiliger und
deshalb sehr bescheiden andererseits ist
es natürlich dass man mit dem alter
weise wird doch ich habe manchmal meine
zweifel und fürchte alles was ich
geschrieben habe sei dummes zeug
schön ist dass der heilige thomas das
geschrieben hat als er noch jung war
er ist mit 49 jahren gestorben aber
damals war das ein recht hohes alter
zudem war durch seinen diabetes sehr
geschwächt
daran ist er wohl gestorben denn er war
sehr dick und konnte nicht mehr der
ärmste warum sehen sie nicht bei thomas
bei ihrer begeisterung die man spürt
warum sind sie nicht bei thomas von
aquin geblieben warum haben sie sich das
erotik der lehre der zeichen der lehre
der warum haben sie sich da semiotik
dann zugewandt ich habe begonnen mich
mit der semiotik zu beschäftigen weil
ich vor allem ästhetische interessen
hatte meine dissertation schrieb ich
über das mittelalter aber über die
mittelalterliche ästhetik dann
interessierten mich aus verschiedenen
gründen nicht nur die kunst bewegungen
der avantgarde
sondern auch die massenmedien ich suchte
nach einer theorie die alle diese
verschiedenen aspekte der kommunikation
vereinigt so bin ich auf die semiotik
gekommen um zu erklären was sie mutig
ist habe ich 30 jahre an der universität
gearbeitet und gelehrt das kann man
nicht in zehn minuten zusammenfassen
nehmen wir also etwas über das wir schon
gesprochen haben
der mensch ist das einzige tier das
lacht der mensch ist das einzige tier
das um seine sterblichkeit weiß und der
mensch ist das einzige tier das sich für
nicht vorhandene dinge in passiert und
mit anderen darüber redet während wir
zwei hunde oder beeren würde ich dieses
buch geschnüffelt
sie würden es beschnüffeln und dabei
blieb es da wir menschen sind können wir
über zürich reden das nicht hier ist
oder über meine mutter die vor 30 jahren
gestorben ist
über abstrakte begriffe wie das
rechtwinklige dreieck über das konzept
der sprache und so weiter wir können
also über dinge reden die nicht hier
sind während der hund schnüffelt einer
spur gefolgt dass ich diese verliert
diese musik befasst sich mit der
unendlichen nicht nur verbalen methoden
mit denen sich menschen über dinge
unterhalten können die nicht hier sind
sie vermögen sogar zu lügen
dank der semiotik können wir nicht nur
über reale sondern auch über ihre
wir reden über mögliche welt und wir
können das gegenteil der wahrheit sagen
obwohl die wahrheit nicht viel mit
semiotik zu tun hat das ist eine
annegret philosophische idee aber die
semiotik befasst sich auch mit den
verschiedenen arten mit denen wir die
wahrheit angehen oder wie wir lügen
dh es sind eigentlich so eine idee
sie erklärt die politik das fernsehen
zeigt wird alles das heißt sie haben die
semiotik weit geöffnet auf die kultur
hin also diese lehre
ich würde sagen diese trockene lehre der
zeichen der symbole haben sie auf die
kultur hin geöffnet sie sind so eine art
thomas von aquin der semiotik sie haben
den menschen in dieser logik
hineingebracht
das war wunderbar sagen sie mir wie
viele ich ihnen für diese schöne
behauptung bezahlen soll
wir können noch weiter gehen thomas von
aquin war der und wörter oder theologie
dazu kommen wir aber das ist ein hier
anlegen oder lodges zu öffnen auf die
kultur hin dass die kommunikation nicht
nur denken sie an die analyse von roland
barthes er sagte weil andere nur dinge
sehen entdeckte sie mutiger den sinn
wenn normalsterbliche jemanden sehen
bemerken sie vielleicht dass er eine
jacke trägt der semiotik hingegen sie zb
am schnitt und der beschaffenheit der
jahr
welche modischen strömungen der träger
angehört ich denke da an semiotik die
sich mit kultur befasst haben wie der
große semiotik ouzo und später der
russische philosophie juli lottmann
auch ich habe natürlich die semiotik auf
viele aspekte der zeitgenössischen
kultur angewendet ich möchte noch etwas
hinzufügen dass ein wenig provokativ
fest die heutigen jugendlichen bedienen
sich ständig der semiotik der kultur
aber sie vergessen die grundlegenden
aspekte der philosophie zu diskutieren
in meinen jüngsten büchern kehre ich
deshalb zurück zu den großen
philosophischen problemen der semiotik
die es schon gab bevor man von semiotik
sprach es sind die probleme der
erkenntnistheorie und heute der
kognitiven wissenschaften die sich damit
auseinandersetzen wie das gehirn die
welt erfassen kann
eine entscheidende frage ist auch gibt
es gibt es eine ursprüngliche frau eine
ursprüngliche sprache oder gab es
mehrere sprachen also es gibt die
geschichte in der bibel kennen es elf
die geschichte vom turmbau von babel das
eben es gab eine sprache dann wollten
die menschen diesen hohen toren der
himmel berührt bauen sie wurden von gott
zerstreut in mehrere sprachen es gibt
verbracht gehen es ist 10
da steht es gab eben verschiedene völker
die ganz natürlich auseinander gegangen
sind also es gibt schon da in der bibel
eigentlich zwei erklärungen was gibt es
ihrer meinung nach eine ursprüngliche
einheitssprache stellen eine schlaue
frage wohl wissend dass ich ein buch
über die suche nach der vollkommenen
sprache geschrieben habe darin zeige ich
auf das die perfekte sprache eine utopie
ist
und zwar in zweierlei hinsicht denn es
geht eigentlich um zwei utopie die erste
ist die ursprache von adam die dann
verloren gegangen ist
die andere utopie ist die einer
perfekten sprache die allen erlaubt sich
zu verständigen
beide utopien erweisen sich beim genauen
hinschauen als katastrophal
und vergessen wir nicht voll die
geschichte vom turmbau zu babel steht in
der genesis 10
dass die menschen in die welt hinaus
zogen alle mit ihrer eigenen sprache
auch in der bibel gibt es also die
sprachenvielfalt vor dem turmbau zu
babel
anscheinend ist es so wenn es zwei
menschen auf eine abgelegene insel
verschlägt er finden sie eine andere
sprache
fünf kilometer von meiner geburtsstadt
entfernt spricht man einen dialekt den
ich schon nicht mehr verstehen das heißt
folgendes und war schon die idee von
epikur für den menschen ist es wichtig
eine sprache zu schaffen die der eigenen
gruppe und umgebung entspricht sobald
man sich fortbewegt und zwar nicht von
der schweiz nach schweden sondern nur
wenige kilometer weit verändert sich die
sprache das ist also eine weitere
nur dem menschen eigene besonderheit die
hunde bellen überall in der welt gleich
die menschen hingegen sprechen überall
anders es gab also die ursprache von
adam nicht im siebzehnten jahrhundert
hat der französische calvin ist dies
aktuell arber einen skandal ausgelöst
aufgrund neuer chronologien entdeckte er
das außereuropäische kulturen wie die
chinesische viel älter sind als die
hebräisch also sagte er sich babel der
lösung durch jesus alle diese dinge
gelten nur für den nahen osten
die übrige welt hat eine andere
geschichte erlebt natürlich für sei
deswegen beinahe auf dem scheiterhaufen
gelandet weil er die intuition hatte das
für die menschen den sprachenvielfalt
wichtig ist auch wenn uns heute die
wissenschaft sagt dass die menschheit
vermutlich von einem einzigen ort in
afrika stammt und sich von dort
ausgebreitet hat theoretisch müsste es
daher auch eine ursprache gegeben haben
es finden sich denn auch ziemlich
seriöse wissenschaftler die von einer
ursprache namens noch statisch regen
doch da es keine geschriebenen zeugnisse
davon gibt wird man das nie genau wissen
mit bestimmtheit lässt sich einzig sagen
dass alle menschen das gleiche apa
rädchen im gehirn haben das ihnen
ermöglicht sprachen zu kreieren und zu
verstehen und dass sie dieses apa
rädchen ihrem sozialen umfeld angepasst
haben
wir haben einige probleme der
sprachphilosophie berührt ich würde gern
mit ihnen über einige themen nach der
politik des zeitgeschehens wo sie sich
auch immer regelmäßig wieder essays zu
wort melden berühren
ich habe ein zitat von claudio magris
dem ein schriftsteller kollegen aus
italien von ihnen dem
friedenspreisträger des deutschen
buchhandels in diesem jahr er sagt über
silvio berlusconi er hat den schlechten
geschmack zu seinem stil gemacht
wie lebt es sich sowieso in berlusconi
ich bin einverstanden mit meinem freund
claudio magris
zusammen haben wir die vereinigung
freiheit und gerechtigkeit gegründet um
in italien gewisse themen aufzugreifen
und die demokratie zu verteidigen
lebt es sich gut denn berlusconi gibt
den italienern was die hälfte von ihnen
wünscht seine entgleisungen und
vulgarität sind gewollt denn sie werden
von mindestens 50 prozent der italiener
akzeptiert sie sind mit berlusconis
fernsehsendern groß geworden er hatte
die generalität die italiener auf den
moment vorzubereiten wo er die bühne
betrieb seien schlechter geschmack und
seine vulgarität sind genauestens
kalkuliert er weiß nur zu gut wenn man
ihn beschuldigt leichte mädchen in
seinem palast eingeladen und mit ihnen
sex gehabt zu haben
hätte die hälfte der italiener gerne das
gleiche getan vielleicht auch die hälfte
der schweizer beweis
damit spielt er vielleicht die kleinere
hälfte aber es ist aber einer seiner
spitzen moderatorin mike bongiorno ist
vor wenigen wochen gestorben er hat ein
staatsbegräbnis in mailand mailand der
dom erhalten
sie haben schon 1961 über ihn
geschrieben über diesen moderator mike
bongiorno er repräsentiert ein ideal das
zu erreichen sich niemand anstrengen
muss denn jeder ist schon auf seinem
niveau
keine religion war je so nachsichtig mit
ihren gläubigen aber ist es nicht etwas
einfach als intellektuellen dass ich
dann auf diese seite zu begeben
das habe ich 1991
60 beschrieben ich weiß nicht wie bon
giorno privat war aber als öffentliche
person des fernsehens präsentierte sich
als durchschnittsbürger mit der gleichen
in brands und dergleichen
und während mich mein kleiner zeh
jahrelang verfolgte hat das fernsehen
bongiorno längst weit hinter sich
gelassen
sein ideal war der durchschnittsbürger
in den letzten 30 jahren ist jedoch das
fernsehen immer mehr dazu über gegangen
menschen zu idealisieren die geringer
sind als otto normalverbraucher jene die
big brother produzieren oder das
sogenannte trash fernsehen
während bongiorno wie ein kleiner
postangestellte und ein taxifahrer
argumentierte dass der heutige
fernsehwelt der dorftrottel die man
früher in der dorfkneipe einen ausgaben
auf den tisch dick und etwas zum besten
gab
natürlich habe ich eine falsche zahl
nannte sie nicht 50 prozent der
italiener berlusconi kam mit 30 prozent
der stimmen an die macht aber das reicht
das fern sie in der letzten jahre hat
ein publikum geschaffen das es
eigentlich auch schon früher gab
wenn ich an die leute denke die sich
kasko spellen kämpfe anschauten
was ist das mark hat einen schönen se
darüber geschrieben
es ist ein derber freisteht kampf in die
massige sumo-ringer ähnliche männer mit
mäßiger intelligenz sich wild verprügeln
und in den schlamm werfen in hamburg
zeigt frauen dasselbe tun solche
scheußlichkeiten fanden schon im einzel
willkommen durch das fernsehen wurde es
einfach
heute werden die betrübte typen und
frauen händler in alle programme
eingeladen und man tut als wären sie
helfen das privatfernsehen hat also
diesen geschmack geschaffen den
berlusconi verkörpert meine frau ist
mehr wie sehen sie die rolle des
intellektuellen in einem land in dem der
ministerpräsident der lüge und des
steuerbetrugs angeklagt ist
es ist nicht gesagt dass der
intellektuelle immer etwas ausrichten
kann
ich war stürzte meinung wenn es in einem
theater brennt muss der intellektuelle
nicht auf einen stuhl steigen und
gedichte rezitieren sondern er muss die
feuerwehr benachrichtigen wie jeder
andere bürger in gewissen situationen
kann der intellektuelle nichts anderes
machen als immer wieder seine ablehnung
kundzutun
die vereinigung freiheit und
gerechtigkeit organisiert zusammenkünfte
wie schreiben der junge schriftsteller
roberto saviano lehnt sich mit seinen
büchern gegen das system der kamera auf
kürzlich habe ich in einem artikel
darauf hingewiesen dass das
faschistische system von den
universitätsprofessoren verlangt hatte
einen treueeid auf das regime abzulegen
alle kamen der fiel nach einigen sogar
auf anraten der kommunisten oder von
benedetto code der gesagt hatte dass ihr
legt diesen ab dann könnt ihr wenigstens
an der universität bleiben
0 12 weigerten sich und mussten
auswandern
diese zwölf haben die ehre der
universitäten und des landes gerettet
manchmal heißt intellektueller zu sein
zu diesem 12 zu gehören und die ehre des
landes zu halten
und was machen eigentlich die linken was
macht die linke in italien falsch das
ist das andere problem und das was sie
berlusconi genannt haben ist ein
gemeinsames produkt von berlusconi und
der link die linke hat keinen
charismatischen führer mehr und ihre
vertreter machen nichts anderes als
miteinander zu streiten
sie servieren berlusconi also auf dem
silbernen tablett die absenz der
opposition
[Musik]
wenn es kritik zum beispiel in den
zeitungen kommt sie von den
intellektuellen aber nicht von den
parteien die linke zerfleischt sich
selber davon profitiert berlusconi
natürlich und verantwortlich dafür dass
die italienische linke persönlichkeiten
ich sage jetzt nicht wie dolly aktiv
sondern die berlin wo er oder bertini
gibt es nicht es ist eine schwer zu
glauben in so einem großen land was ist
jetzt zu tun
auch das römische reich ist
untergegangen sind
hier und da geraten die länder in eine
krise wie gesagt die behauptung 50
prozent der italiener seien für
berlusconi ist übertrieben denn
statistisch gesehen sind es 30 aber
sicher sind mindestens 50 prozent bereit
auf die straße zu gehen um zu
protestieren
und wir haben auch ein gericht das
urteil gefällt welche die verfassungs
werte verteidigen
wir stecken mitten in einem ideen streit
in dem berlusconi aufgrund seines
wahlerfolgs eine immense macht hat
vielen italienern pasta so ein
multitalent wenig rosig
sie melden sich regelmäßig zu wort sie
schreiben auch in einer internetzeitung
im golem in dispenser wille
was wollen sie verteidigen außerdem gut
immling die spencer will habe ich meine
14 tägliche rubrik im espresso
daraus würden verschiedene dinge im
golem aufgegriffen den ich mit ein paar
freunden gegründet habe
dabei geht es immer darum sich kritisch
zu äußern
ich kann ja nicht in den
regierungspalast gehen berlusconi packen
und hinauswerfen
das wäre undemokratisch ich kann also
nichts anderes tun als immer wieder nein
sagen
manchmal ist es die einzige aufgabe des
intellektuellen zu sagen nein da mache
ich nicht mit
gibt es ein privatleben für sie sind sie
ein familienmensch zé kladow ich habe
ein privatleben sehr guter großvater vor
allem aber habe ich kaum noch
öffentliche auftritte
seit ich mit der name der rose diesem
großen erfolg hatte kann ich an keine
kunst vernissage oder theatervorstellung
gehen ohne dass ein journalist mir das
entgegenstreckt was wir die laternen und
mich fragt was ich von diesem und jenem
halte deshalb habe ich mich stark aus
dem öffentlichen leben zurückgezogen und
treffe mich nur noch mit einigen
freunden
ich habe also mehr zeit für ein
privatleben was wollen sie ihre tochter
ihren 1963 war mein sohn knapp ein jahr
alt da schrieb ich einen text der auch
auf deutsch erschienen ist
[Musik]
darin schrieb ich wenn du größer bist
schenke ich dir waffen
denn um ein wahrer pazifist werden muss
man als kind viel mit waffen gespielt
haben
die stelle mir vor dass mängel reichmann
göring als kleine kinder mit dem
chemiebaukasten und solchen dingen
spielten
ich hingegen spielte mit pistolen und
gewehren und bin heute frei von
jeglichem verdacht ein waffennarr zu
sein und ich habe eine lange liste von
waffen erstellt meine erste liest drei
seiten lang mit namen von waffen die in
allen abenteuerromanen aus der ganzen
welt gefunden habe was soll man also
seinen kindern weitergeben
solche ideen nicht eine liste warfen
aber die haltung dass man keine waffen
anwenden sollen
ich bin zufrieden
mein kleiner enkel ist heute neunjährige
sehen und selten da in hohen wohnt
einmal hat er mich gefragt hast du eine
frank kennengelernt
das heißt in der schule davon erzählt
und er dachte wohl wenn wir uns gekannt
hätten wir uns sicher verstanden also
sagte ich ihm ich hätte sie nicht
persönlich gekannt ich sei noch ein kind
gewesen als sie starb und wir haben uns
darüber unterhalten
so kann man ideen und seine kinder und
enkel weitergeben indem man mit ihnen
spricht mit ihnen spielt nicht in die
man vorträge hält bei einer beinahe
religiösen dimension sie haben mit dem e
marginal von mailand carlo maria martini
einem jesuiten ein buch herausgegeben
woran glaubt wer nicht glaubt sie haben
darin gesagt die ethische dimension
beginnt wenn der andere ins spiel kommt
klingt nach existenz philosophie
gewisse philosophen wie man als
existenzialisten bezeichnen könnte wir
immer nur webinars aden von anderen
gesprochen doch den begriff des anderen
gibt es in vielen philosophischen
richtungen und kulturanthropologie wir
definieren uns über das ausmaß an
kontakt den wir mit anderen haben das
ist ein weiteres merkmal des menschen
wenn uns auf der straße niemand
anschauen oder ansprechen würde wenn man
uns isolierte in einem grausamen akt von
mobbing sterben wir womöglich das
gegenüber ist also sehr wichtig für uns
deshalb konnte jesus vom nächsten
sprechen es ist etwas das die menschen
verstehen sie wissen was mit dem
nächsten gemeint ist auch wenn sie ihn
umbringen
deshalb habe ich in diesem gespräch
zwischen einem gläubigen und
nichtgläubigen die figur des anderen ins
spiel gebracht als anfang aller
ethischen probleme bevor mir jemand vom
berg herunter die gebote kund getan hat
aber sie würden sagen um ein guter
mensch zu sein um ein mensch der eine
ethiker zu sein muss man nicht an gott
glauben
ich denke es gibt viele gute menschen
die an gott glauben aber es gibt auch
viele gute menschen die nicht an gott
glauben gott mit dem namen gottes auf
den lippen wurden schlimme verbrechen
begangen während nichtgläubige für andré
ihr leben geopfert habe deshalb sage ich
dass die ethik etwas umfassenderes ist
als die religion
sie entsteht wenn wir im kontakt mit
anderen entscheiden müssen was wir tun
können und was nicht um mit ihnen
zusammenleben zu können
ein freund von mir sah marco schreibt
immer wieder die religionen würden ihnen
zu gewalt und kriegen anstiften man
könnte ihm leicht entgegnen im lenin und
stalin waren nicht religiös und haben
trotzdem schlimme dinge getan
schön ist dass es nicht davon abhängt
man kann gutes oder schlechtes tun
unabhängig davon ob man an gott glaubt
oder nicht
das gute und schlechte gab es eigentlich
schon vor der entstehung der religionen
man denke nur ein plan der eine theorie
des guten entwickelt hat ohne dass es in
seiner philosophie einen gott gibt für
mich gibt es ihn bei aristoteles wenn er
auch auf sich selbst bezogen ist aber
bei karten gibt es keinen gott sondern
vielmehr die republik der ideen und wert
sie sind im katholizismus aufgewachsen
haben sich in jungen jahren davon dann
entfernt was sie genau der punkt da da
gibt es unzählige gründe einer ist
fundamental glauben dass sie es nicht
auf vernunft sondern auf gefühlen wie
man erleben kann dass man sich in eine
person verliebt und sie hinterher hast
so kann man den glauben verlieren
gehörte katholischen organisationen an
und es kam zu zusammenstößen mit der
katholischen rechten
es gab also auch politische gründe ein
grund war auch meine auseinandersetzung
mit thomas von aquin
ich setzte ihn in seine zeit und
distanzierte mich durch eine art
verfremdung von ihm
ich verstand er merkte aber auch dass er
nichts mehr mit mir zu tun
ich war nicht er allmählich
ich brauchte mehr als acht jahre des
schweigens gewissermaßen um mich von
dieser neuen haltung durchdringen zu
lassen und weg war der glaube
einmal fragte mich ein katholischer
schriftsteller was passiert wenn sie
sterben und gott begegnen ich sagte
machen sie sich keine sorgen wir beide
haben die gleichen bücher gelesen wir
werden uns finden
dank für dieses gespräch
[Musik]